things is being able to have desire you
have needs you can go to the mall and
take care of them and you can you've got
once but desires are very very huge it's
very hard to know what you really what
what what you desire the erotic desire
you know well some of that desire is
what the Greeks called paphos which is
an unfulfilled longing for the beyond so
that you always want more so that it's
never enough
and that feeling that it's never enough
is nobody's fault it's given with the
figure of eros had three phases
immediate desire him arose which is like
physical wanting and immediate physical
connection and then ant eros which was
answered love and love couldn't move
unless it was answered faced back and
forth and then the third one was pothos
which was for the beyond so that and
that's never fulfilled and that occurs
in that's the kind of nostalgic longing
for the unknown and it may have appeared
first when you were 14 years old some
some extraordinary song that holds you
or some Beatrice for Dante some
something that's it's the great romantic
longing and that's a desire that creates
the wings and is behind a lot of
romantic art and music and and the
longing the fellow told me one of these
seminars very interesting sentence he
said the way the only solution for the
longing for union is union with the
longing
very nice sentence the the solution to
the longing for union is the union with
the longing see we don't stay with a
longing we want it fulfilled and the
essence of the longing is that it can't
be fulfilled so your what your needs can
be fulfilled but not that not that
transcendent longing so by staying with
the by union with the longing realizing
you are a creature of longing the
romantic said tell me what you're long
for German romantics and I will tell you
who you are
tremendous sentence we say what do you
do and you fill out your social security
form you know or your tax thing tell me
what you long for and I will tell you
who you are
they made a great deal of same suit that
kind of nostalgic I don't know what
other word to use for it longing and
it's more than the desire that the
French are using this jury souls desire
I think it's something much more than
that
[Laughter]
[Music]
and you you weep and you call somebody
on the phone and you make a note you've
heard it turn it over
you do what everyone else does
but in your back seat you're thinking
literally about how do I make salt like
give me the recipe and that isn't the
point the point is to have a fantasy
that what you're doing makes oh you're
still asking me concretely how now that
is an American problem the house as I
said the other day on TV Americans are
great it means and not very good at ends
in other words we know how to do all
kinds of things we know how to multiply
information endlessly but we have no
idea of why why all this information or
what the point of it is and no criticism
about it or anything else we know how to
do everything and we ask always how we
are geniuses at application like the
Japanese are geniuses of miniaturization
no the Chinese invented the fan the
Japanese invented how to fold it